はい、どうも中島です。ということで本日
の動画なんですけども、本日は
ノートブックLMを使った記事の書き方を
解説していこうと思います。正直迷いまし
た。ま、前からね、ノートLMを使ったり
して記事書いたりしていたんですが、
あまりにも有益すぎて出すのを躊躇してい
たんですが、ま、でもせっかくだったらね
、有益なものを見てもらえる方がいいかと
思って動画にしてみます。もしかしたら
消すかもしれません。はい。で、今日の
動画を見ていただくと、ま、ご情報の
少ない、え、品質の高い記事を簡単に
作れるようになるかなと思います。それ
こそチャATGPTとかクロードとかそう
いうのに丸投げしてですね、なんとかの
キーワードで記事を書いてみたいなこと
だけやってる人よりもかなり、え、品質の
高いものを作れるようになるので是非
楽しみにしてください。で、今はですね、
ま、どのAIを使うかっていうのもちろん
重要なんですよ。チャATGPT使うのか
、クロード使うのか、ジムニ使うのかとか
、そういうのも重要なんですけど、それ
よりも重要なことはですね、そのAI、ま
、どういう風に組み合わせて使っていくの
かというのが非常に重要なポイントですね
。その組み合わせ方っていうのでもう
出来上がってくる、ま、成果物の品質って
いうのは大きく変わるので、今回はノート
LMとその他のAIをいくつか使いながら
記事を作っていこうと思うので、よかっ
たら参考にしていただければと思います。
で、今回のメインになるノートLMですね
。ま、これについて、え、動画でも何回か
紹介をしているんですけど、一応知らない
方もいると思うので、まさか知らない方は
いないと思いますが、万が一今日この
チャンネルを知ったという方もいるかも
しれないので、一応ノートブックの紹介
からしていこうと思います。ノートエレム
とはGoogleが提供するAIリサーチ
ツールです。ま、ソースを指定して調べ物
ができるというのがノートエレムの特徴
ですね。ま、その総々になる、ま、元に
なるもののっていうのは本当に、え、
いろんな形式を、ま、総例、ま、音声とか
動画とか、あとはネットの記事とかですね
、あとテキストとかPDFとか本当に
いろんなものを突っ込んで、ま、それをも
にいろんな、え、質問ができたりするって
いうのがNotebookLMの特徴です
ね。ま、これGoogleがやって
るっていうのも結構大きいなところですね
。そのどこの企業か分からないところが
やってるんじゃなくて、Googleが
ちゃんと出しているものだというところ
ですね。個人的にはこのノートLMが、ま
、1番このビジネスマンとかね、仕事の
生産性を上げるために手っ取りものかなと
思っています。めちゃくちゃ使いやすいし
、分かりやすいので、使ったその日から
すごいなという風なことは実感して
いただけるかなと思います。ノートの解説
をする動画ではないので、ノート11のね
、その細かい仕様とか機能とかそういう
ところに踏み込んでいくわけではないん
ですけど、もしね、興味があったらノート
エレムの動画もあるので、そちらを見て
いただくか調べていただければと思います
。で、今日はノートベックAを使った
ブログの書き方っていうの紹介していくん
ですけど、そもそもですね、なんで
わざわざノートベックAも使わないといけ
ないのかというところですね。それこそ
チャットGPTとかに投げてしまえば
チャッピーに投げたら別にすぐに記事
できるじゃないかと思うかもしれないです
けど甘いんですよ。これですね、AI記事
には問題点があります。で、何が問題
かって言うとですね、やっぱり
ハルシネーションとかご情報の問題って
いうのがめちゃくちゃ大きいんですよね。
それこそ普通に何か質問をした時でも
間違った情報が返ってくるっていうのが
あるんですけど、これがですね、ブログの
記事とかになると割と知名的なことになる
わけです。だって何かのメディアで記事を
書くっていうところに間違った情報が出て
いたらそのメディアどうなんてなるじゃ
ないですか。メディアって正しい情報とか
、ま、最新な情報って正確なものが書かれ
てるっていうのが非常にいいところで、
例えばテレビとか、え、新聞とかで間違っ
た情報がバンバン出ていたらそんなもん誰
が見んねんって話で、ま、そういう風な
状態になってるメディアって結構あるん
ですよね。今だったらそれこそ記事作成に
AI使ってないメディアの方が少ないん
じゃないかなっていうぐらいなんなら全部
フルAIで作ってますみたいなサイトあっ
たりしますよね。それこそ
Wiキペディアiaみたいな、ま、
グロキペディアっていうものがあってです
ね、ま、それイロマスクさんが作っている
、ま、Wikipediaみたいなやつな
んですけど、そのコンテンツは全部AIが
作っていると。だからこのAIが作ってる
からハルシネーションとか普通に
めちゃくちゃあるんですけど、ま、それが
あのすごいアクセスを稼いでいったりする
んで、ま、間違った情報がね、拡散されて
いてそれが問題になっていたりしますけど
、ま、AIってのはどうしてもそういう
問題があるということで、じゃあこれを
どうしたらいいのかと言うとですね、解決
策あります。教えましょう。解決策は
リサーチをしてソースをつけてから執筆を
してもらうですね。もうこれが1番
手っ取りやし、1番確実な解決策です。と
はいえ、それで100%ハルシネーション
がなくなるわけじゃないですけど、自由に
AIに欠かせるよりは格段に
ハルシネーションを減るし、え、ご情報も
減ります。なので基本的には記事を書か
せる時には何かソース元になるね、その
文章の元になるソースを与えてあげて文章
を書かせるっていうのがおすめです。で、
そのソースになるものとして、え、今回は
ノートブックエレムを使うという感じです
ね。で、この方法について結局
ノートフックAは何かを早々与えてそこ
からあのブログ記事に変換していくわけ
ですけど、そこがま、パクりなのか、ま、
それがリサーチなのかっていう教会戦が
非常に曖昧でここについてもう気になる方
がいるかもしれないので、ま、これは法律
の問題もあるんで、なかなか僕が法律の
専門家ではないので、あ、だ、こうだって
断定した言い方はできないんですけど、僕
の考え方を言うとですね、この
ノートブックを使ったブログ記事の書き方
っていうのは特にパクりに当たるような
ものではないのかなという風に思ってい
ます。例えば何かの記事を書く時に、え、
ネットのいろんな情報をリサーチしてその
上で記事を書くってのはこれ普通にやる
わけですよ。今までAIが出てくる場合
だったら人間がそれをやっていたわけなん
ですけど、その人間の作業っていうのを
AIに大体してもらってるだけなんで。だ
から結局人間が手でやるのか、時間をかけ
て手でやるのかAIで短時間でやるの
かっていうところの違いだけなんで、だ
からこれがパクりに当たるっていうことは
ないかなという風に思っています。
あくまで人間のリサーチを時短しただけと
いうような認識ですね。はい。もちろん
やり方によってはね、そのパクリになっ
たりとか著作権の問題があったりとかって
いうのはあるかもしれないんですけど、ま
、僕のざっくりの認識としてはそういう
感じです。で、ここでなんでノートブック
エレモを使うのかということですね。ま、
そのソースを添付する形で文章を書かせる
とその方がハルシネーション少なくなるよ
ねっていう話をしたんですけど、これね、
ノートブックLMのめちゃくちゃ大きな
特徴があります。何かって言うとですね、
ハルシネーションが非常に落ちにくいん
ですね。ま、グラウンディングと言われる
、ま、技術があるんですけど、それを使っ
ているのでノートベックLMっていうのは
めちゃくちゃハルシネーションが起こり
にくいです。ま、要はソースに基づいて
回答する仕組みですね。はい。なんで
さっきも言ったんですけどノートLMに
いろんなPDFとか音声とか、ま、ネット
の記とかそういうのを突っ込むと、それに
基づいて回答してくれます。はい。で、
ソースにその情報がないとないっていう風
に言ってくれるのも親切なところなんです
けど、なのでその今ある既存のものを引用
してちゃんと答えてくれるので
ハルシネーションが非常に少ないと。ここ
が大きいところですね。そもそもここの
ところにハルシネーションがめちゃくちゃ
入っているとこれを参考にして記事書いた
ところでハルシネーションがあの入って
しまう。間違った情報が入ってしまうよ
ねってなるからここがご情報少ないっての
はめちゃくちゃ重要なところなんですけど
ノートブックエレムはそういうのが非常に
え、少ないような仕組みになってい
るっていう感じですね。あと個人的には
スライドとか音声化というのもボタン1つ
に簡単にできるっていうところもポイント
が高いですね。ま、それこそ全然自分の
知らない分野とかそういうところで肘とか
ね、ノートLM使うことがあるんですけど
、その時にもちろんあのノートックLMに
ね、そのソースを元に色々と調べてもらっ
てこう出力してもらうっていうのはできる
んですけど、ま、でも自分その分野は知ら
ないのでそこを勉強したいよねっていう時
に、ま、スライドを見る方が分かり
やすかったりとか音声だったらその移動中
でもね、それを聞きながらいろんな勉強が
できるっていうところで、ま、非常に利用
価値は高いかなと思います。ただ注意点と
してはさっきまでちらって言ったんです
けど、あのノートブックAMだったら
ハルシネーションなくなるのかってったら
ハルシネーションなくならないです。あの
他のAIに比べたら極めて少ないですけど
それでもハルシネーションなくならないの
でそこのところは注意をして欲しいなと
思います。はい。ということで前提にして
実際に記事を確定順を画面を見せながら
やっていこうと思います。はい。是非手元
にパソコンある方は一緒に作業しながら
やればと思います。LLMを無料診断や
はということでまずはノートックLM
を使います。え、Googleアカウント
あれば簡単に入れますし、無料で使えるの
で、え、まずはノートレムね、ログインし
てください。で、ノートブックを作成で、
え、ノートブックの画面を開くとこんな
感じになってると思うので、まずはソース
を追加していくことになります。投稿して
もらって、ま、いろんなね、ファイルを
アップロードしたりとか、ウェブサイトの
URLを突っ込んだりとか、あとは、ま、
Googleドライブだったり、テキスト
をそのまま突っ込むとか、いろんなことが
できるんですが、ま、ここのところで、え
、ネットで検索をしてもらって引っ張って
くるというのがやりやすいかなと思います
。ま、色々ね、あの、選択肢もあるんです
けど、で、ファーストリサーチとディープ
リサーチに関しては、ま、ファースト
リサーチはパッてね、10秒とか20秒
ぐらいで、え、結果を返してくれるもの、
ディープリサーチはもっともっと詳細に
調べる代わりに、ま、時間かかるもののっ
ていう感じで捉えてもらったらいいかなと
思います。ま、この辺の切り替えは、ま、
テーマとかね、どのぐらい専門性の高い
記事を書きたいかっていうところによって
変えてもらえばいいかなと思います。ま、
どっちも使いますね。どっちかっていうと
個人的には専門性の高い調作結果が欲しい
のでディープリサーチ使うこと多いです
けど、ただディープリサーチ使うと本当に
5分とか、ま、下手したら10分ぐらい
かかったりもするのでかなり長いので、だ
からパッてやりたい時はファースト
リサーチですね。今回はあの動画のために
やるので、え、ファーストリサーチの方を
使っていこうと思います。え、そしたら
どうしよっかな。クロードコードとかにし
ますか?最近話題のクロードコードについ
てちょっと調べてもらいましょう。はい。
こんな感じ。ま、もちろん文章で打つこと
も全然できますけどね。ま、要するにどう
いうテーマを調べて欲しいかっていうのを
ここに入れてやるとノートAMの方で、え
、ウェブサイトリサーチしてこんな感じで
出してくれます。一瞬ですね。え、10秒
ぐらいですかね。そうするとこの、ま、
候補の、え、ウェブサイトがこんな感じで
出てくるので、え、ここで、え、不要な
ソースがあれば除外してあります。あの、
この手順1番大事です。このノートベック
A使った、え、ブログ地の書き方の中で
おそらく1番大事なのがこの、え、不要
ソースの除外だと思っています。なので
ここは丁寧にやる方がいいです。え、
クロードコードについて、ま、どういう
ことを書いて欲しいかっていうところも
あるんですが、うん、例えば、ま、今
イメージしてるのが、え、クロードコード
の記事なんで、使い方とかクロードコード
が何なのかとか、ま、注意点とかそういう
のを解説するようなものなので、え、それ
以外のものっていうのは基本的に外して
やった方がいいです。全然関係ないものが
入ってきたりするんでね。それこそ同じ
言葉で2つの意味があるようなものがあっ
たりするんですけど、そういうものだと
全然関係ないものを入れてきたりするので
、なるべく、え、余計なソースはない方が
いいのでいらないものを外してやります。
ま、今回はそこまでこうやって見てると
そんなにいらなそうなものないかなという
風には思うんですが、ま、例えばこれとか
リッハブコパイロットとクロードコードの
この比較みたいなのをしてるんですけど、
別にそんなコンテンツいらないよっていう
んだったらこういって外してやった方が
いいです。あともう1つ、ま、クロード
コードの預金体系とかこの辺もあるんです
が、ま、これもですね、僕は外す可能性が
高いなと思っています。なんでかって言う
とこのここに書かれてることがあってるか
どうか分からないからですね。ま、分かん
ないですよ。別にここについて見てないの
でどうかわかんない。実際はね、開いて
あの中を見たりしてもいいんですけど、ま
、今回は使い方の実演なんでそこまでは
ちょっとやらないですけど。あとこれとか
もまあ学術的調査からクロードコードの
自律的な性能とかって言うんですけど、別
にそこまで専門的なものを求めてるわけ
じゃなかったら別にこういうのも外して
やると、ま、こんな感じですね。はい。で
、今ファーストリサーチなんで、えっと、
ソースの数8件なんですけど、これ
ディープリサーチとかにしてやると何十件
とか出てくるので、なので、それがどう
かっていう感じですね。あの、この、え、
ソースの除外っていうところも大変になれ
ばいろんな情報がご邪魔になるので、ま、
そういうところで、え、後の処理が
ちょっと大変になるのでなので、あの、
簡単にやりたい時とか早く手早くやりたい
時はもうファーストリサーチでで、専門性
の高い詳細なね、え、リサーチしたかっ
たらディープリサーチっていう感じで
使い分けるのがいいかなと個人的には思っ
ています。で、これで、ま、一応不要
ソースの除外をしたので、このまま
インポートをしてやります。はい。ま、
インポートも一瞬ですね、基本的には。ま
、ソースの数が多いとちょっと時間かかり
ますけど、それでもそんなに待ったりはし
ないですね。そうするとこんな感じで、
えっと、ま、概要みたいなね、ま、これら
の、え、インポットしたソースのようやく
というか概要みたいなのがこんな感じで出
てきます。で、ま、ちょっとだけ
ノートブックAMの使い方をやると、ま、
ここに、え、質問とかね、何かお願いを
すると、ま、ここのソースを元に答えて
くれるって感じですね。ま、料金の話をし
たんで、じゃあ例えばクロードコードの
料金について教えてくださいと。あ、
ちなみにこれは全然本題じゃないです。
あの、記事書く上では別にやる必要ない
です。ま、必要だったらね、やってもらっ
ていいんですけど。そうするとこのソース
を元に回答してくれます。ま、料金体系
ガイドっていうのがね、あるんで、ま、
こういうところから引っ張ってくる。
ノートベックのいいところはこうやって
どこから引用してるかっていうのが非常に
分かりやすいところですね。ま、この辺が
いいところだと思います。はい。で、話を
戻しましょう。え、ブログ記事を作る時に
必要なのは、ま、この辺の、え、いろんな
ボタンがあって、ま、これ押すと、え、
ラジオみたいなラジオ風の音声作れるとか
、これ押すとスライド資料作れるとか、
動画作れるとか色々あるんですけど、え、
大体ですね、ブログ作る時はこのレポート
ですね、え、これを使ってやることが多い
です。で、ここにもブログ記事あるんです
けど、ま、これで作るってもそんなにいい
ものにならないことが多いので、僕は個人
的にこれで作ることはないです。ま、
プロンプトのカスタマイズもできるんでね
、こカスタマイズしたらここ押すだけで
それなりのものができるかもしれないです
けど、ま、色々とこっちであれこれ
アレンジとかをしたいので、僕はこの概要
説明資料というのを使うことが多いです。
はい。これをしてやるとどうなるかって
言うと、ま、ここの、え、インポートした
ソースを元に、ま、概要説明のデポート
みたいなのを作ってくれると。これは
テキストで吐き出されます。はい。ちなみ
になんかこのクロードコードについて勉強
したいよっていう時はこの音声とか
スライドとかインフグラフィックとかこの
辺を使ってやります。押すだけなんでね、
クリックするだけなんで本当に簡単に使う
ことができます。はい。で、レポートが
できてるんで開いてやります。そうすると
こんな感じ。クロードコードエージェント
型AI開発環境の
プリーフィングということで、ま、
クロードコードについての
情報っていうのがこんな感じで出てきます
。はい。ま、結構やってる人だったらね、
普通に全然この辺のclド.MDとか、ま
、スキルとフックとかMCPサブ
エージェントとか、ま、この辺っていうの
は全然あの馴染みのあるものだと思います
けど、クロードコード使ってない人にね、
何のこっちゃ分からないと思いますが。
はい。こんな感じで、え、記事が出てくる
ので、次は、え、これを元にですね、処理
をしていきます。で、ここで、え、
ティップスなんですけど、一応ですね、
ここで出てきてる内容、ま、言ったらここ
のソースから引っ張ってきてるんですけど
、そもそもこれが間違ってる可能性あるん
ですよね。さっきも言ったけど料金体系の
記事があるんですけど、この料金体系自体
が間違ってる可能性がある。でもそれを
ノートLM自体が分かるわけではないので
、え、できるんだったらファクトチェック
挟んでやるといいかなと思います。で、
ファクトチェックどのようにやるかって
言うとですね、これは僕がこういう風に
やってるよっていうことなんですけど、
ファクトチェック、え、ジェンスパークを
使います。これね、ジェンスパークって、
ま、AIエージェントで、あの、似たよう
なものでね、マナスってありますけど、ま
、AIエージェントといえばマスか
ジェンスパークかみたいなその辺が有名な
んですけど、このジェンスパークって本当
ね、めちゃくちゃいろんな機能があって、
もう日々アップデートされていっても何が
あるのかっていうのを探すのが大変な
ぐらいなんですけど、これ知らない方も
いるかもしれないんですが、ファクト
チェックの機能があるんです。で、個人的
にですね、このジェンスファークの
ファクトチェックかなりよくできてると
思っていて、割と、え、使うことが多い
です。で、どうするかって言うと、ま、
さっきのこのノートLMの、え、文章です
ね。ま、ここを押してやるとコピーできる
ので、このままコピーしてきて、これを
ジェンスパークに貼り付けてやって、これ
で、え、ボタンを押してやります。そう
するとどうなるかって言うと、この中の
内容を、え、ジェンスパックがファクト
チェックしてくれます。で、正直この
ファクトチェックも完璧ではないし、
間違ってるものも全然あるんですけど、ま
、でも体感ですね、8割くらいはちゃんと
ファクトチェックできてるなという印象
ですね。はい。なので、ま、ここでもその
5情報が0になるとかっていうわけでは
ないんですけど、ただここで出てきたもの
をそのまま使うよりもその8割の制度でも
ね、ファクチャチェックして使っていける
方がそれはご情報の少ない品質の高い記事
になるよねっていうところで、え、こんな
感じでやります。で、最終的に、ま、
ちょっとネタバレ的になりますけど、え、
最後書いた後にもここのチェンスパークに
突っ込んでファクトチェックとかするん
ですけど、ただこの時点でファクト
チェックやっとく方がいいです。それは
記化した後にファクトチェックをするって
言ってもそもそも間違った情報で気づかし
てもしょうがないので物によってはね
そもそもこの情報自体がそんな核架空の
ものだったりするとそれを知事に組み込ま
れたところで意味がないのでじゃあそんな
の最初からない方がいいよねっていうこと
でこの時点でファクトチェックしてやり
ます。ただこれがめんどくさいズボらな方
は最終的にファクトチェックをするという
だけでもいいです。とりあえずAI使って
記事を欠かせるとか何かコンテンツを作ら
せるのであればファクトチェック0で出す
のだけはやめた方がいいですね。どっかの
タイミングでもいいのでどこのタイミング
でもいいのでファクトチェックは絶対必須
で入れた方がいいです。はい。ま、そう
するとこんな感じで、え、あれこれ
ジェンスパーク側で処理をしてくれます。
はい。ま、これとかね、え、ま、並列で
検索を行ってくれて必要な情報っていうの
をアーってネット上から集めてくれ
るっていう感じですね。で、ま、後でまた
終わった後に見せますけど、ま、それぞれ
、ま、何をもりそれを言ってるかっていう
ウェブサイトの引用元とかそういうところ
もスクショで貼ってくれるので、その辺も
めちゃくちゃいいところですね。はい、と
いうことでファクトチェックが終わった
ようなので見ていきましょう。そうすると
こんな感じですね。えっと、こんな感じで
、え、判定みたいなのを出してくれて性格
、正確、正確、正確みたいな、ま、こう
いう項目は合ってるよねみたいな。で、
これに関して、え、不正格誤解を読招くっ
ていう感じで出してくれています。ま、
なんでこれ以外は、ま、概合ってるん
だろうなっていう感じですね。で、
それぞれの詳細はこんな感じです。ま、
ここに公式ドキュメントにこういう感じで
書かれてるからこれは正確だよねとかです
ね。で、これに関して、ま、間違ってるよ
ねっていうところ、ま、ユーザーのコード
はモデルのトレーニング使用されないて
いう風に記載されてる事実と異行いますと
。2025年9月の、え、利用規約変更に
よって、Proロ、Maxのユーザーは
設定でオプトしない限りクロードコードの
会話とかコーディングセッションがモデル
学習に使用される可能性がありますという
風に書かれています。え、そうなの?はい
。ということで、ま、こういうのがこんな
感じで分かると。で、これもですね、下に
行っていただくとマジ面白くて、これ結構
僕は感動したんですけど、ほら、証拠の
スクリーンショットってここからこんな
感じで持ってきてますみたいなスクショも
くれます。すごくない?ジェンスパーク
すごくない?こうもっとアピールした方が
いいよ。マジでもっとこの木のアピールし
た方がいい。はい。という感じですごい
ですよね。こんな感じでスクショまでつけ
てくれるんで、ま、なんで、え、ま、
さっきも言ったんですけど、これが絶対に
合ってるっていう感じではないんですけど
、なんか怪しいなとか何を元に言ってん
だろうなみたいな思ったらこの辺を見たり
すると分かるという感じで。はい。なので
、え、これが間違ってんじゃねみたいな話
なんで、ま、ここのところを修正してやっ
て、ま、基地の作成を進めていくっていう
感じですね。で、今回は正直、え、その
まま使います。なんでかって言ったら、
ただのデモだから。
ま、ちょっとね、あの、修正してると時間かかるし、ま、そのディール別にいらないと思うので、
チャットGPT&
コパイロットの教科書、公評発売中です。
はい、ということで、じゃあ実際に、え、記事を書いていくわけなんですが、今回はクロードを使っていこうと思います。ま、日本語に強いと言われているし、ま、僕もね、あの、普通に文章確的クロード使うことが多いので、クロードでやっていきます。で、プロンプター適当です。ま、こんな感じでっ。で、重要なことは、ま、スに基づいて元に、え、替えてくださ
いって風に言うことですね。
で、ここのところに、え、こんな感じで
貼ってやります。あ、クロードなんで
こんな感じで、え、テープされますけど、
ま、いいでしょう。はい。ま、この辺は、
あの、入ってるプランによってもね、違う
と思いますが、ま、僕はレマックスプラン
に入ってるので、オパス4.6使えるので
オパス4.6を使います。では、ポチ、
こんな感じです。ま、あ、は記事書いて
くれるので基本的にそれを待つだけという
感じになります。で、余談ですが、え、
記事書いてる間に時間があるので、
ちょっと追加の説明というか、えっと、今
クロード使ったんですけど、ジムに使うっ
ていう選択肢もありかなと思います。地味
にですね、え、ノートベックALMを
ソースとして添付することができるんです
ね。なので、こっから、え、ノートブック
LMの添付をしてやると、わざわざあの、
貼ったりする手間がなくて楽なので、
こんな感じ。そうするとほらこんな感じで
ノートALMのノートブックを添付する
ことができるので、ま、これであの記事
書いてもらうってのも全然いいかなと思い
ます。ま、ただ今回で言えばね、ファクト
チェックで間違ってるところがあったので
、ま、これを直さなきゃいけないので
ノートベック
をそのまま添付してやると間違った情報元
に書かれてしまうので、ま、その後で直さ
なきゃいけないっていうちょっとめど
くさいことになるんで、ま、直したものを
貼り付けてあげるっていう方がいいんです
けど。はい。ということで、え、できまし
たね。早い。はい。そうするとこんな感じ
で、え、記事書いてくれます。
クロードコードとはエージェント型
AI開発環境の展望と活用法徹底開
2026年最新。おお、SEO
っぽい。そうするとエージェント型AI
とは何かとかですね。ま、クロードコードを使いこなすワークロー
とかですね。ま、こういうことわって書いてくれると。で、
cloudド.MD
とかそういう話があるんですけど、こういうのもノートック
でね、え、リサーチした結果っていうのを元に書いているっていう感じですね。
なので、ま、そのまま何もね、ソースを
添付しない形で投げてしまうとこの辺の
ハルシネーションていうのが非常に増える
んですけど、え、ソースを元に書かせて
いるのでこの辺のハルシネーションも非常
に少ないものが出来上がるという感じです
。はい。ま、何かあればね、追加で、え、
フォローアップのメッセージを送って、ま
、変えてもらうとこあれば書いてもらっ
てっていう感じですね。で、ま、あの、
これでできたっていう風に仮定してですね
、次は何をするかって言うと、そうです。
ファクトチェックです。とにかく僕から
伝えたいことはファクトチェックをしろ
です。はい。こんな感じで出来上がった
ものを貼ってファクトチェックしてやり
ます。ま、あの、基本的にはソースを元に
書いてくれるんですけど、ただソースを元
にしてないような文章っていうのも当然
入ってくるんで、基準にする段階で。ま、
そこに間違った情報が入ってると、また
ハルシネーションとかご情報の音証になっ
ちまうので、ま、そういうのを防ぐために
、え、再度ファクトチェックをしてやり
ます。はい。で、さっき言い忘れたんです
けど、これジェンスパーク使ってファクト
チェックしてるんですけど、
例えばチャットGPTとか、ま、クロード
とかね、そういうの使ってファクト
チェックしたらいけないのかって言われ
たら別にいいです。別に何使ってファクト
チェックしてもらってもいいです。ただ、
あの、ジェンスパックが個人的には、ま、
よく使っているし、え、かなり優秀だと
思っているので、ま、これを使って
るっていうだけで、ま、ジェンスパック
使おうと思うと、これはこれで、えっと、
サブスクが入らないと、ま、そこまで使え
ないと思うので、ま、なので、え、
ファクトチェックとかね、ま、本気でし
たい方はというか、これと同じ方をし
たかったらジェンスパーク使ってもらって
、ま、そうじゃない、え、環境でやりたい
。例えばチャットGPTの有料プラン入っ
てるから、それでやりたいって方は全然、
あの、チャATGPT使ってファクト
チェックしてもらってもいいかなと思い
ます。ま、でも色々やりましたけど
ジェンスパックが一緒です。はい。
クロードコードとか使える方はね、
クロードコード使ってファクトチェック
するとかそういうのもいいかなと思います
。個人的には複数でファクトチェックする
ことは多いです。え、クロードコード、
ジェンスパークみたいな。で、え、
ジェンスパークで出てきたものをクロード
コードに戻してこの本当みたいなのをお
互いにやり取りさせて、え、最終的に
ファクトチェックしていくみたいな、ま、
そんなやり方をすることが多いですね。
実務的には。はい。ま、あとはもう
ファクトチェックで同じような、え、結果
が返ってくるので、もうこれで一応一通り
の作業としては完成ですね。ま、ただこれ
、えっと、あくまでね、クロードコード
全体の骨組みたいなのを作っただけなので
、ま、これをもっと品質の高いものにして
いくんだったらここに、え、自分の経験と
か、え、そういうものを足していいものに
していくっていう必要があります。それ
こそ一時情報とか体験とかですね、そう
いうのを入れていく。AIにはそういうの
ができないので、そこは自分で入れていく
方がいいかなと思います。ま、こ、この
記事でもそこそこいい記事なんですけどね
。でも面白みがそんなにあるかって言っ
たらそこまで面白みはないので、やっぱり
そういう記事としての面白みを足すんだっ
たら自分の一時情報とかを足していくのは
大事かなと思います。あの、僕だったら
それこそクロードコード最近すごいね、X
で話題になってるんですけど、僕結構前
から使っていて、2025年の2月ぐらい
に一般リリースされてると思うんですけど
、その頃からクロルコードずっと使ってい
て、ま、本当にその時はまだまだ今に比べ
たらもう使いにくかったんですけど、でも
結構その時から使い倒しているんで、一時
情報とかね、あの、体験弾っていうのは
めちゃくちゃ持っている。ま、システム
開発やつも車内システムが多いんですけど
、そういうのも本当にたくさん作ってて、
稼働してるやつだけで5個ぐらい稼働し
てるんで、今車内で実際ね。だから、ま、
その開発の経験とかそういうところもある
んでね。だからそういうのをクロード
コードで例えばclロード.MDでこう
いう風な使い方が推奨されてるけどでも
そんなんやっても意味ないよねみたいな。
ま、今だったらね、それこそクロド.MD
に前はめちゃめちゃいっぱい書いてあるこ
でね、指示をしていたんですけど、指示
いくら書いたところで結局それが100%
守られるわけでもなく、ま、クロード
コードへの、ま、ルールとか指示をそこの
cloud.MDに書くっていうルールに
なってるんですけど、それいくら書いた
ところで抜け物がいくらでも起こるから、
ま、お待ちない程度でそんなに何も書か
なくなりました。ま、その方が個人的には
なんか運用もしやすいし、それで特に困っ
てないのでそれでいっかみたいな。ま、
クロード.MDにね、いくら指示を書いた
ところで意味がないから、それこそスキル
に、え、映したりとかフックに移したりと
かっていうのをしてる。ま、この辺の
クロドコードの話はまた何か別の機会で
話そうかなと思うので、興味があれば是ひ
チャンネル登録をしていただければと思い
ます。はい、ということで、え、結果が出
てきましたね。十分なエビデンスが集まり
ましたということで、え、ファクト
チェック結果を並べてくれています。はい
。こんな感じです。ま、基本は同じですね
。てか全部同じなのかな?同じっぽい。
ま、早々ごとに書いてるんでね、書かれてること自体がそんなに変わるわけではないので、ま、最後のここだけはやっぱり不正性格という風に判定されますね。はい。なので、ま、実際に記事にする時にはここのところは直さなければいけないということですね。
ウェブライター専用マッチングープラットフォーム.net、詳しくは概要欄をチェック。
はい、ということで、え、ノートを使った記事の書き方ということで話をしてきました。
どうだったでしょうか。ま、実際に、え、
こういう記事の書き方してる人っていうの
は非常に多いと思うし、それかこそ
チャットGPTとか、え、ジムニーとか
クロードとかそういうの単体で使ってる人
はこういう記事の書き方ってあんまり
思いつかなかったりやってない人が多いか
なと思うので、え、参考にしてもらえる
部分は結構あるんじゃないかなと思います
。そう、そう、そうだよ。こういうのが見
たかったんだよっていう。そこのあなた
是非コメントください。ま、正直、え、
こういう内容死ぬほど持っています。ま、
冒頭でも言ったんですけど、あんまり出し
たくないところもあるので、ま、その仕事
でね、え、使っていて、あんまり手の内を
晒らしたくないなというところもあるので
、ま、今までそんなにやってこなかった
部分もあるんですけど、ただそういうのを
見たいという読者の方が多かったらそんな
内容を増やしていこうかなと思うので、ま
、何をやろうかなっていうのは結構ね、
うちのこのweブショTV自体やってる
ことが多いので、それこそブログの話し
たりとか、SEOの話したりとか、AIの
話したりとか、マーケティングっぽい話を
したりとかっていう結構幅が広いので、
なんかどこをやっていこうかなっていうの
は結構悩んでるというか、迷ってるところ
ではあるので、なので、ま、今日のこう
いう内容とかね、本当に、ま、実用的な
ものでうちがやってる事例とか、ま、そう
いうところで参考になりそうなものをやっ
て欲しいっていう声が多かったらそういう
ものをやっていきたいなという風に思って
いるので、是非、え、ご意見、感想など
あればコメント欄に書いていただけると
嬉しいです。はい、ということで本日の
内容が参考になったと思ったらチャンネル
登録、コメント、高評価よろしくお願いし
ます。
では今後も実的なテクニックをたくさん紹介していくので楽しみにしてください。今日の動画はこれで終わりにしたいと思います。ありがとうございました。
最短30日でウェブライターになれる実践
型スクールWWです。